I'm kind of can give me one more at
least let's see because we got a few
more people waiting and then I'll
probably call call you back but what's
the other one let's see yeah yeah this
one's very long I took a long time with
this
one
yeah was there a way for the
Gentiles uh to be saved in the Old
Testament of course if you have you read
First Kings chapter 8 when Solomon
erected the temple read that entire
chapter it's a long chapter he he built
that temple with the hopes that if
anyone among the Nations realizes that
the god of Israel is true and he turns
towards the direction of that Temple
Because he believes God's presence in
there God would hear that Gentile and
forgive him and receive him into
himself okay so First Kings chapter 8
the entire chapter tells you one of the
functions of the temple was for the
priest to make
sacrifices for the sins of all the
nations and the hopes that if anyone
from the nation
turned towards the direction of the
temple and recognition that the god of
Israel is a true God and His presence
was there in a special way and that he
acknowledged the god of Israel as his
God God would receive his prayer and
forgive him and Grant him salvation it's
right there in First Kings chapter
8 okay
so just so I'm clear here in First Kings
chapter the entire chap you got to read
it yeah in fact let me give you an
article on this I wrote go ahead you
were saying that go ahead
it even back then even though we were
not Jews or Israelites or whatever you
want to we weren't God's chosen people
we still had access to his salvation and
his mercy and his grace course what
what's the point of the entire Old
Testament what we just read what was
this point what was the point of all
these verses what did God want the point
was to make it uh set the example
through Israel or the Israelites or the
Jews however you want to look at
was to set the example for them and then
bring everybody else exactly to them and
so what if people among the Nations then
turn to the god of Israel and turn
towards the direction of the temple
because they believe okay that Temple is
the house of the god of Israel his
presence is there in a unique way and
I'm going to turn towards the temple
because I acknowledge their God is my
God what do you think God would
do he's a loving and merciful god so
imag he'd say you're forgiven not
imagine that's First Kings 8 it's right
there I just gave you the Articles they
would be forgiven God would accept them
and bless them as long as they focused
on the god of Israel and sought his
favor here it is I just sent you the
links to the articles in fact let me
prove that to you from the story of
Jonah Jonah what did you what what
happened to the ninevites when Jonah
preached to them and at his preaching
they repented where the king and all the
people and the animals put on sackle as
a sign of mourning and fasted it says
God forgave them and relented from
destroying them so are we to assume that
that means that though God relented from
destroying them and forgave them they
weren't saved or is that a sign of God's
favor and salvation to that particular
generation who recognized the god of
Jonah as the true
God that would be a Reconciliation a uh
forgiveness there you go it's right
there right okay so in the old Testament
you see God is saving people from the
nations in fact in second Kings chapter
5 let me give you another one second
Kings chapter 5 it's a long one so I'm
just summing up because it's too long in
second Kings chapter 5 it says that
there was the the general the commander
of the army of Syria his name was nonon
or Naman Naman or namon however you want
to pronounce it now Syria was one of the
Nations that was a thorn in the sight of
Israel and of Judah Naman had leprosy
leprosy of the skin he was told that
there's a prophet in Judah that could
heal leprosy
Elisha so he goes and meets Elisha he
travels from Syria to the land of Israel
Elisha sends a servant to tell non Naman
dip yourself in the Jordan River seven
times now man dipped himself seven times
in the Jordan River came out and was
healed miracul lessly his skin became
fresh like that of a newborn baby and
then he realized that the god of Elisha
is the true God that the god of Israel
is a true God but then something
interesting happens go to 2 Kings
chapter 5 read verses 15- 19 2 Kings
chap 5:
15-9 guys I'm giving you the links to
all these articles there are three
articles one is a two-parter here's one
more here's the third one that's the
third one about this how did the how did
God in the Old Testament save the
Gentiles 2 Kings chapter 5 what verses
again verses 15 to 19 and here's the
other article brother I just sent you
the links to all three okay thank you
now read that for me 2 Kings 5:15
to19 then he returned to the man of God
and uh sorry he and all his company and
he came and stood before him and he said
behold I know that there is no God in
all the Earth but in Israel so accept
now A present from your servant but he
said as the Lord lives whom I serve I
will receive none and he urged him to
take it but he refused then namon said
if not I beg you let there be given to
your servant Two Mules burden of Earth
for henceforth your servant will not
offer a burnt offering or sacrif
sacrifice to any God but the Lord in
this matter may the Lord pardon your
servant when uh my master goes into the
house of Ron to worship there leaning on
my arm and I bow myself in the house of
remen when I B myself in the house of
remen the Lord pardon your servant in
this matter he said to him go in peace
now let me explain what he was saying
here Naman said I'm gonna give you a
gift for what you did for me and Elijah
said no I'm not going to accept anything
from you because God healed you I didn't
it was God who healed you because I
didn't do anything then now notice what
Naman asked guys pay attention this is
something very important for you guys
learn your theology Nam man says to
Elisha I want some dirt from Israel
because why this land is the land of
your God given to you so I want a
remnant of this land a part of your land
to take with me so that I will then put
it on you know in the ground on his
house wherever and that will be
consecrated and I will then offer
sacrifices to your God on that dirt that
you've given me because that dirt comes
from the land that your God has given
you but I ask for one
favor my king will enter into the Temple
of his God reman to worship ran I
acknowledge it's the god of Israel
that's the true God not Raman however I
have to accompany him him and bow with
him even though my heart I don't worship
Raman because he's not a true God in my
heart I'll be worshiping your God who's
the only true God allow me to do this so
that your God won't punish me and then
Elijah said you're free go in peace do
as you
desire you see that that's 2 Kings 51519
so was Naman saved yes non Naman was
saved did he acknowledge that the god of
Israel is the only true God yes
did he acknowledge Raman the god of his
king the king of Syria was a false god
yes but was he still allowed to attend
the king and go with the King into the
Temple of the king's false god and bow
with him even though in his heart he's
worshiping the god of Israel yes and did
God pardon for that
yes there you go that's how they were
saved once you acknowledge the true God
and in the articles I gave you you'll
find that there was a practice of the
high priest to offer 70 Bulls over a
span of time and according to Jewish
tradition this is in my articles and I
give you the citations I gave them to in
the links Jewish tradition the reason
why 70 Bulls were sacrificed over a
period of
time again the exact period of days
escapes my mind Lord will I'll do a
session on it is because the priest was
offering a a sacrifice for the 70
nations of the world why because if you
go to Genesis 10 and you count the table
of Nations there are 70 total and so
Jewish tradition says that God required
the high priest to offer 70 bulls for
the sins of the 70 Nations just in case
any one of those Nations or people among
those Nations turned to the true God and
repented so that their sins would be
atoned for
in my articles that I sent you the links
to so hope that answered the question